we've been talking quite a bit over the
last few months over this question of
whether a sitting president can be
indicted and the reason that this is a
relevant question is because of our
current president we know that our
current president directed his attorney
Michael Cohen to commit multiple
felonies Michael Cohen by the way being
sentenced right now as we are recording
the show we'll have news about that for
you tomorrow we are still waiting to
find out what degree of illegal
coordination with a foreign power took
place during the 2016 election we're
waiting to figure out what is Robert
Muller aware of when it comes to
obstruction of justice and witness
tampering so we may at some point go
from the theoretical to the practical in
having to figure out can a sitting
president be indicted or would a sitting
president have to be impeached first
before indictments could follow if
indeed that president wasn't pardoned
preemptively this is all in the realm of
opinion right there is no law which says
you can indict a sitting president there
is no constitutional provision which
would prevent the indictment of a
sitting president it's not been tested
whether you can indict a sitting
president but we've heard lots of
serious legal opinions over the last six
months which say you wouldn't be able to
do it we have now a contrasting opinion
which I'm going to present to you today
and it's from Lawrence tribe who's a
legal scholar and a professor at Harvard
Law School here in the Boston area who
simply disagrees with the assessment
that you can indict a sitting president
he says oh yeah a sitting president can
be prosecuted no problem and in fact
it's part of how the framers of the
Constitution
wanted a president who is not immune
from consequences if they do the wrong
thing tribe wrote an op-ed piece in The
Boston Globe this week where he simply
says ok the Justice Department might
have a sort of de facto policy where
they would not indict a sitting
president but such a policy tribe argues
would be unconstitutional and tribe
actually points out
specifically that the strategy predicted
by conservative columnist Jennifer Rubin
earlier this week is likely to be
exactly why indictment of a sitting
president as possible Rubin suggested
and we did this clip for you earlier in
the week that Donald Trump would resign
ten minutes before the next Democratic
president would be inaugurated that
could be in 2021 that could be in 2025
so that Mike Pence would be President
for those last 10 minutes of Trump's
term and would issue a pre-emptive
pardon making it so that Donald Trump
could not be indicted after he leaves
the White House we know that the framers
of the Constitution took very seriously
that we shouldn't have a king in the
United States and that there have to be
ways to deal with a potentially corrupt
or criminal person becoming president of
the United States so thus leaving
presidents free to sort of cash in these
get-out-of-jail-free cards with
pre-emptive resignation and pardoning by
their vice presidents who could be just
as corrupt as they are we don't know yet
when it comes to Mike Pence but the Vice
President could be just as corrupt as
the president it seems unimaginable as
what the framers would want that they
would want such a system where a
president can effectively make
themselves not vulnerable to any
consequences to their actions the point
that tribe makes in the op-ed which I
encourage you to read yourself is that
no matter what your view is on why you
can't indict a sitting president that it
would be unconstitutional if the Justice
Department has a policy that says we
don't indict sitting presidents tribe
argues that would be unconstitutional it
definitely doesn't seem that such a
formal policy exists but what if the
president can always preemptively have
themselves pardoned by the VP that also
would be unconstitutional if indeed
there is no other way to make or to
subject a president to consequences
tribe argues still for now this is in
the realm of the theoretical but it's
getting closer and closer to becoming a
real issue rather than merely a
theoretical
closer than it's been in a very long
time in American history and meat we may
well see it tested in the coming years
the entire perspective of Lawrence tribe
and those who by the way when I've
mentioned that the the wealth the
overwhelming majority of legal opinions
I've read say you can't indict a sitting
president people write to me and they
say no David that that's not accurate
their view is effectively we have a
president and not a king any system
which truly puts the president
off-limits from consequences is what we
would see in a theocracy or a
dictatorship not the type of government
that the framers established the problem
with this entire argument Pat is that it
does sort of depend on constitutional
interpretation and inferring what the
framers had in mind
that's a minefield when it comes to
something this serious well I certainly
hope that if this is litigated they
would find that you can indeed indict a
sitting president and I'm not just
saying that because Trump is president
or because the Republicans president I
just buy into this idea that no person
should be above the law and that
includes the president and how bad would
it be for the country if this Coast of
the Supreme Court and they vote
completely on party lines like all five
conservative justices say that you can't
indict a sitting president and the four
liberals say that you can I think
they'll be really bad for the country
once again for everybody who said
supreme court doesn't matter Trump
versus Hillary doesn't matter it's all
basically gonna be the same
yeah we're quickly seeing that that's
not the case one last thing on this I
got a question in the email from a
viewer who said if Trump can be indicted
and is indicted and goes to prison but
the Senate still controlled by
Republicans won't vote to remove him
after the house files articles of
impeachment could we have a president
running the country from prison in
theory you could realistically you would
think that the cabinet would determine
okay the president can't carry out their
duties from prison and that the cabinet
would use the 25th amendment to remove
Trump in that case would Betsy DeVos
actually cast that vote though in that
case I hope so although I don't really
know